♪♪
Justin Paul:
Making a musical, it’s so
special and it's so thrilling
Justin Paul:
because for one brief moment,
you're watching hundreds of
people
all speak the same language at
the same time.
♪♪
Ian Eisendrath:
This is one fifty-five for one
fifty-seven.
Ian Eisendrath:
We want to make sure it’s sort
of forte piano and massive crescendo.
Ian Eisendrath:
Okay.
♪♪
Ian Eisendrath:
The musical brief for Spirited
is to create a score that
becomes a Christmas classic.
Justin Paul:
So much of our process is
strategizing,
“How does this song deliver what
we need to deliver for each
moment?”
♪Am I forever unredeemable?♪
Benj Pasek:
When you’re working on a script
you kind of, it’s like a flashlight
where you can only see a little
bit in front of you and then you
have to have faith
Benj Pasek:
that you can keep going.
And like, things reveal
themselves to you the more you
sort of shine that light and
eventually you get to where
you’re going.
Ensemble singing:
♪We have to believe inside♪
♪the worst of us♪
Ensemble singing:
♪there is some decency there.♪
Mark Sonnenblick:
Sometimes you find an incredible
moment of emotion
Mark Sonnenblick:
for a character or an idea that
could become
musicalized that just leaps out
of the dialogue and becomes a
song.
♪I am forever unredeemable!♪
Ensemble:
♪Unredeemable!♪
Justin Paul:
The great thing about this story
is it goes to so
Justin Paul:
many different places because
the material
and the plot allowed us to just
go there each time.
Clint:
♪Oh it would be sure,
simple.♪
It has everything from a epic,
Bernard Herrmann film score-
Ensemble singing:
♪We're bringing back
Christmas!♪
Clint:
♪And all the joy that we’ve
lost!♪
To contemporary pop gospel.
♪That’s the view from here.♪
To a big, London British
musical.
Clint/Present/Ensemble:
♪I was walking through the
streets of London-town♪
Clint/Present/Ensemble:
♪where freaky sleep will wake me
up and strip your people down!♪
Sukari Jones:
It was so fun to contain all
these different
facets and then mesh them
together.
We had a ton of opportunities to
bring in
dancers and big choirs and,
which is just a thrill to get to
record them and, and have that
sound.
Ensemble:
♪You're gonna wanna say♪
Khiyon Hursey:
This score has been
mind-blowing.
I’ve never heard anything like
this in my entire life.
Ensemble:
♪So do a little good!♪
Clint/Present:
♪Do a little good!♪
Ensemble:
♪Give a little more!♪
Justin Paul:
It’s a very special experience.
I don’t know that we’ll ever get
this kind of chance, or this kind of
experience again so we’re trying
to soak up every single minute
of it.
Ensemble:
♪Do a little good!♪